[Music]
Japanese chemist kakuni ikada was
sitting down to eat a bowl of Dashi he
stopped eating took a moment for pause
and declared that it was the greatest
soup he'd ever eaten Ika had made a
genuine scientific discovery there was a
fifth taste and he named it umari when
you eat something and it instantly coats
your entire mouth with a deep rich
almost meaty flavor that's Umami as a
matter of fact that day soup was
prepared with the addition of KOMU eada
dedicated all his time to investigating
why simple sliver of seaweed made his
soup taste so superb ikita discovered
that the taste he' experienced was
caused by an amino acid called glutamic
acid you may have heard that word before
within the context of mono sodium
glutamate MSG and so he crystallized
seaweed broth to create a powder a
powder that he could then add to any
other food during the cooking process to
supercharge its taste and mouth feel
basically Yik had created the crack
cocaine of the food world